a one liter reaction vessel contains 1.2
moles of carbon monoxide 1.5 moles of
hydrogen gas and 2.0 moles of methanol
gas
how will the total pressure change as
the system approaches equilibrium at
constant temperature
so our carbon monoxide is reacting with
our hydrogen in a one to two ratio to
give us
methanol and this reaction is reversible
we also know the equilibrium constant
for this reaction is 14.5 at some
temperature
and we know that the temperature is
staying constant
so we are going to break this problem up
into two parts
in part one we're going to try to figure
out using the reaction quotient whether
our system is at equilibrium or not
so for this reaction
our reaction quotient q
is the product concentration ch3
oh or methanol
divided by the concentration of our
hydrogen gas to the second power because
of that stoichiometric coefficient
and then also in the denominator we have
our carbon monoxide concentration
we can calculate q by plugging in the
concentrations of these
at this particular moment in time
and we can calculate the concentrations
using
the volume of the vessel which is 1
liter
and the mole quantities
we know that concentration
is just
moles divided by volume since we're
dividing everything by one the initial
concentrations will be the same as
the number of moles
so if you write that out for carbon
monoxide
the initial concentration is 1.2 molar
for hydrogen it's 1.5 molar
and for methanol it is 2.0
molar
so now we can plug these concentrations
in to our expression for q
and then we get
in our numerator 2.0
and our denominator
is 1.5
squared times 1.2 so if we plug this all
into our calculators what i got is that
our q for this particular moment in time
with these concentrations is 0.74
so this tells us first of all we know
that q
is not equal
to kc
so that means we are not at equilibrium
not
at equilibrium
which means that our pressures are
indeed going to change because the
system is going to try to reach
equilibrium the second thing we can do
using the reaction quotient 2 is figure
out how the concentrations will change
now that we know our reaction quotient q
we know that
our reaction quotient qc is less than k
we can visualize this on a number line
so if we look at all possible values of
q
we know that when q is zero we have all
reactants
when q is
infinitely large we have
all reactants
we have all products
and then we have all of the possible
values in between
what we're really worried about here is
just looking at the relative value of q
and k
and seeing how the reaction
concentrations are going to shift
so q we can put on a number line is
somewhere around here
and k
is 14.5 so we'll say it's somewhere
around
here
so this is our q
and this is our k
we can see that q is less than k on our
number line and so what's going to
happen is
in order to reach equilibrium
our concentrations are going to shift to
the right to get q closer to k which
means what's going to happen is
reaction the reaction
is going to shift to favor
making more products
so
if we look back at the balanced reaction
what's going to happen here is it's
going to shift
to favor
the products
so i'm making that top arrow a little
bit more bold and to tie this into what
the problem wants to know we can figure
out how the shift to make more products
will affect the total pressure
so total pressure for a system that has
a bunch of gas molecules in it we know
that
total pressure is related to
the moles the moles of gas in the system
so since we're shifting
to favor the reactants and on the
reactant side we have
we're making one mole of gas and we're
starting with three moles of reactant
gas we're favoring the side that has
fewer gas molecules
so that means as we shift to favor the
products
we're going to reduce number of gas
molecules in the system and that's going
to reduce our p total
so the answer is that p total
is going to decrease
as our reaction
approaches equilibrium and that is
because
our reaction quotient q
is less than k